self-driving cars are already here
widespread adoption of this technology
will lead to a traffic less pollution
and fewer car accidents these cars bring
to light a long-standing hypothetical
dilemma how moral should we make our
robots what if an autonomous vehicle is
faced with a choice to either kill its
passenger or kill others how should it
be programmed in online surveys
participants approve of autonomous
vehicles that sacrifice the driver to
save many others basically a utilitarian
approach that aims to preserve the most
amount of life but respondents would
prefer not to buy these kinds of cars
and they don't want regulations that
require self-sacrificing algorithms in
fact such regulations would make them
less willing to buy a self-driving car
the rise of autonomous vehicles creates
a social dilemma roads would be much
safer if there are more autonomous cars
but programming that would actually make
driving safer might prevent people from
buying these vehicles imagine shopping
for a car and having a choice a car that
sacrifices a driver on occasion or a
preserved passenger at all costs car
what would you do